ladies and gentlemen maga's Revenge I
was excited to see it uh the house has
adjourned with no speaker uh I I I dig
it I do look man I'm not a republican
I've been saying this for the past
couple of weeks I don't care for Kevin
McCarthy in 2016 it was reported that he
apparently there's a recording where he
said Trump was being paid by Putin or
something like that okay Kevin McCarthy
said Donald Trump Bears responsibility
for January 6. things like that this is
a guy who is not interested in the
actual We the People it's establishment
garbage all the way now look Marjorie
Taylor green very much wants him to win
a lot of people have said it's because
she's got a quid pro quo well yeah he's
going to put her on committees if he
wins so she's like I want him to win
we're gonna get things done I don't see
anything wrong with that other than I'm
not a republican I'm not going to
support Kevin McCarthy so when he loses
three times in a historic failure I was
just laughing the whole time
um I I look I get it Jeffries is going
to be worse for a lot of reasons than
McCarthy here's how here's the fear
there's I think 434 people who are
voting because there's one vacancy you
have to get a majority of votes cast in
order to become the speaker that means
the only way the Democrats can win is if
Republicans vote Democrat maybe it's
possible the fear is if this drags out
too long Dem moderate Democrats and
Republicans establishment corporate you
know uniparty are going to be like can
we find 218 people to just put like Liz
Cheney as Speaker of the House and then
they'll do it there's enough people to
do it I'm not entirely convinced though
because I don't think someone like Liz
Cheney could actually pull it off but a
lot of people are basically saying if
Kevin McCarthy wins you'll get some
things you want if he doesn't win and
then there's some kind of uniparty shill
who who gets the vote spot because the
the Democrats and Republican uni party
will vote for him then we're worse off
I'm kind of like what's the difference
what's the difference between Liz chain
and Kevin McCarthy like don't come at me
with that I don't like the Republicans
okay there's a handful I like Thomas
Massey's cool Matt Gates and Lauren
bobert I think were awesome today they
stood up and said no but Liz Janey
Michael Mouse had the sweet Liz Cheney
was the one who was uh introducing Kevin
McCarthy nominating him to be speaker
back in in 2021 so it's just like you
think I'm looking at Kevin McCarthy like
oh he's so much different from list
chain yeah he's same thing same thing I
don't know if Jim Jordan's gonna be the
right guy either but I'm just sitting
back laughing that it's been 100 years
since a failure of this proportion hit
and you know what I think
The Establishment is so accustomed to
getting whatever they want that they are
that they don't know how to handle
something like this if it is only 20
people who have rejected Kevin McCarthy
so be it that is a good sign when the
Democrats were nominating Nancy Pelosi
and the squad threatened to withhold
their votes unless they got Universal
Health Care Provisions they caved
instantly and voted for Pelosi and now
what's happening is all the Democrats
are Lexi we're a unified party and the
Republicans are in disarray yeah there
was one person who tweeted that the
Republicans are so authoritarian they
that all of them now are fighting
because they demand they get their way
or else whereas Democrats are all about
democracy so they're in agreement and
I'm like oh okay dissenting is
authoritarian and marching in lockstep
with the corporate Democrats that's
that's not fast get out of here so I
don't know what do you guys think are
you happy to see uh McCarthy lose or is
just a big waste of our time I like the
way Matt Gates stood up and spoke about
it I actually have a tweet from Alx on
Twitter and you might be referencing it
in this article too with from the hill
but he said basically like what Marjorie
Taylor green may have done is I want to
vote for McCarthy because he's going to
put me ahead of a committee but Gates I
don't want to be part of a puppet
committee well he said you can't drain
the swamp if you appoint an alligator
into a position of power which is a
pretty big statement okay said that uh
yeah Bravo oh and uh you know no
personally you know government gridlock
is uh is a part of my love language so
uh seeing what's happening right now is
pretty cool it's pretty awesome and it
shows you that you know the the
Republicans are aren't just the foot
soldiers aren't just obeying every
single order and they're willing to
stand up for larger ideas and principles
there was allegedly negotiations between
a lot of the dissenting individuals and
McCarthy McCarthy allegedly this is what
we're hearing from Lauren bobert and
other people didn't concede to any of
these larger demands MTG very
interestingly is coming out and saying
hey these guys are asking things
personally for themselves I'm not even
getting anything from all this so it's
interesting to see all this debate
personally I hope there's no speaker I
hope there's no Congress I hope there's
just deadlock I hope they're just
arguing and fighting each other all the
time so they leave us alone that's my
personal dreams Gates said they
threatened to pull them off committees
unless they voted for McCarthy absolute
Insanity you said it to me I'll be like
okay now I definitely won't what do you
think CJ if you're a congress member who
would you vote for you know not anyone
I'm in Europe but I think the Silver
Lining to all of this is that literally
until there is a speaker you cannot
swear in a single one of these people so
maybe we don't need a speaker and maybe
that means that the House of
Representatives cannot inflict any
further damage upon any people who
actually value limited government in
this country
um you know and it's a shame to see that
like literally if you are an everyday
American and you fail to do a basic duty
of your job you are fired these people
cannot even elect a speaker of the house
it's absurd yeah I say fetterman for
speaker I mean why not let's make this
happen and also it doesn't have to be a
congress member it could be anybody
trying to become speakers
you name it let's put him in there but
mix it up change it up a little bit I'm
sick of these politicians and plutocrats
and people who don't give a damn about
us let's totally change it up but let's
get let's get Ronald McDonald in there
he'll do a better job than all of them
seriously the the prediction Market's
been pretty wild Kevin McCarthy is
currently leading on predicted followed
by Steve scalise then Jim Jordan Jim
Jordan's dropped down he was at 12 cents
earlier but Kevin McCarthy actually got
knocked out of the top spot for Steve
scalise it's been bouncing up and down
nobody knows right you want to talk
about wisdom of the crowd most people
unpredicted right now they're leaning
towards it's probably going to be Kevin
McCarthy that's why it's 45 cents per
share he's the lead but it's been
bouncing some people think Steve scalise
will be because he's in a leadership
position he will be the compromise and
I'm just kind of like
yo the first vote happens in the house
and you need only five defectors to
block McCarthy and they vote for like
Biggs and they were a few a few other
votes like you know just random people
well I should say random people but you
know a person will get like one vote
then you get Matt Gates nominating Jim
Jordan
Jim Jordan nominating Kevin McCarthy
then it goes to a vote again and this
time Jim Jordan gets 19 votes so ever
like the the never you know McCarthy
faction unifies then it goes to the
third vote
you know the third vote Jim John got 20
votes it actually went McCarthy went
down yeah Byron Donald's flipped his
vote right exactly Jordan good this this
I'll tell you what exactly what I saw
people like why is Marjorie Taylor green
supporting Kevin McCarthy because she
wants to be on committees she doesn't
have the power to go up against the
establishment the best position she
could get is you get Kevin in she gets
on committees she can actually do
something
but
I don't think it'll be enough I think
what they'll do is McCarthy will get
them in committees where they'll have
just enough power but not really enough
to do anything you get Jim Jordan maybe
you'll get something a little bit better
I'm not even convinced Jim Jordan's
gonna be the right guy he didn't even
want he doesn't even want the job anyway
but Kevin McCarthy already moved into
the speaker of the house office
if it's gonna happen I mean it's
politics Anything Could Happen they
could bring out the the FBI and CIA and
the Epstein tapes and that could be uh
all voting in unison right away so so
that could also happen or they could
bring up the internet history that they
have on them or are there private
information and data that they have on
them but MTG made also some very
interesting comments that I think are
worth considering and talking about she
was saying we need to vote for Kevin
McCarthy because the Republicans could
actually get rid of the 87 000 IRS
agents that are supposed to be uh
inducted into the IRS that's her kind of
explanation to it but again I I
personally love the the fighting myself
yeah I'm shaking my head so hard over
here it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna you you put Kevin McCarthy in a
speaker and he's going to be like well
hold on we got to play by the rules I
mean there's a way to do this oh come on
spare me dude I'm the guy who claims
Trump was being paid by Putin the
Republican look Republicans teamed up
with Democrats to stop Trump to stop
Margaret to stop America first I'm not
interested I just don't care I am
actually turned on by humility and the
fact that this Jim Jordan guy who I
don't know doesn't want the position and
he's willing to nominate someone else
but they still want him for the role I
think he's the right guy contrary to
what Kevin McCarthy's been saying it's
my turn I earned it if you don't give
this to me you're embarrassing the party
and the nation it's like that type of
entitlement is the last thing we need in
leadership in Washington today so it's
like yeah I'm right there with you we
need humility we need someone who
doesn't want it at all yeah but Jim
doesn't want it because he wants to be a
part of committees uh and exactly and
wants to investigate allegedly the FBI
and the intelligence agencies allegedly
would he be like neutered at his ability
if he were to become that the speaker
yes and then we also talked to Lauren
bobert just a couple days ago so
specifically I had a conversation with
her and I asked her hey we need a new
church commission style hearing I was
like what's what's the chances of that
happening uh if you guys don't know what
the church commission hearings are it's
where all the dirt about the
intelligence agencies in the 70s was
revealed it was the heart attack gun it
was the infiltration of the corporate
media it was incredible incredibly
important hearings that actually had a
little bit of accountability when it
came to the intelligence agencies I was
like what's the possibilities what
substantias and she was like not that
good so I mean allegedly she's
negotiating with Kevin McCarthy trying
to get something done here is that a
part of the negotiations I personally
hope so we'll see look
bobert said they're working on it that's
something they do want but look at how
many you get 20 people to defy The
Establishment good I'll take it but I
just you get these these these
establishment people in all of this is
gone investigation of Joe Biden I doubt
will happen and if it does it'll be so
weak and pathetic it will be end up
being nothing it will be okay yeah we'll
do the investigation and then they're
gonna go find some homeless guy and be
alike see what you can find and they're
gonna come 10 bucks yeah sometimes it's
worse to do a shell of an investigation
than no investigation because they'll
try and put it to rest with the normies
when in fact they haven't actually done
anything I've done a single year that's
that's a 20 right there Ian rolled a
straight 20. I think that nist did that
with the 911 uh World Trade Center I
mean that thing that commission had
holes all through it if you want to look
at that yeah they will do an
investigation and they'll ignore 99 of
of you know Joe Biden and his family
they'll focus on little tiny things here
then claim it's debunked and say look we
did your investigation and it was
debunked that that's why I'm like nah
not these guys
Select Committee sorry go ahead yeah now
look at the Benghazi select committee
like what actually came of that nothing
of substance you didn't see any people
go to jail you didn't see anyone
actually be really investigated maybe
it's time we actually learned from the
left at least the j6 committee whether
or not you like it or not
um and it was absolutely disgusting in
the way in which they weaponized the
federal government against people who
disagree with their beliefs but maybe
that's what we should be doing in terms
of looking into how the federal
government has actually been weaponized
against conservatives throughout this
country we're seeing it also in the
Twitter files someone someone chatted if
Jeffries wins there will be no there'll
be no investigation at all I'm like yeah
that's actually uh the point Ian was
making that's better if there's no
investigation we can eventually get one
if they do a sham investigation they'll
be like we already did your
investigation we found nothing you're
wasting our time and then with the
normies they're gonna be like oh that
was debunked wasn't it yeah so it's
almost better to have no investigation
than a fake one with someone like Kevin
McCarthy Republicans when who are
actually Democrats driving uh driving
the speed limit or Republicans are is
that saying am I getting it right
um wait yeah Republicans Or democrats
driving the speed limit oh yeah yeah
that's right yeah so you know that that
could be a no for me dog
Randy
[Laughter]
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time